hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
from Monday
September 4th
2023 what's going on how are you
how's it going oh Billy jet lag
Oh Billy dragon is freckled bottom all
across the goddamn world over here
um
Jesus Christ
I did my show in Dubai and I have
um my show in Prague tonight
um 16 hour flight
you know what's funny is I actually find
flying LA to New York or New York to L.A
uh more brutal than literally flying 16
hours
oh is that right bill that doesn't make
sense it's five hours and change
how would 16 hours be better right it's
it's the mindset
you know when you got to fly five hours
across the country six hours across the
country it's like ah Jesus Christ here
we go right
and what the [__] is Bing Bong and now
on these goddamn things shut up
um
anyway
you know you're gonna get on the plane
and you're just gonna be awake you know
unless you take a [__] red eye
from LA to New York
then you sleep
on that one but then you wake up you
feel like you booze the night before
because you don't get eight hours
you stumble out into a [__] you know
Uber a car service to train or whatever
and
you know I don't I don't take the
[__] train because for whatever
[__] reason
New York City New York concrete jungle
where dreams are made of [__] Subway
doesn't go to the airport all of these
people flying in and out of that [__]
thing the fact
they came up with this incredible subway
system that they've never built
subway stops that you got to get on
another [__] goddamn [__] train
you know
you already loved your [__] luggage
down the goddamn stairs you're already
stood there you fought off some [__]
homeless people or whatever you get on
the [__] train
you got to go through all of Manhattans
standing up because it's all [__]
crowded you finally get to the outer
boroughs
and you get a goddamn seat
and then you gotta [__] go back up
the stairs where the [__] is it where
what do I do now then I gotta go over to
here buy another [__] thing go back
upstairs or down some stairs to get on
this [__] thing that the person isn't
even driving
I remember when they first tried out
that thing over at JFK some poor bastard
got on it and got killed
they're like all right guess we got to
tighten the screws down no one's died
since but it's just it doesn't make any
[__] sense it makes no goddamn sense
to me
um
so I always do like a car service and
then what ends up happening is she you
you get off the red-eye flight you
[__] groggy
some guys holding a sign up for you you
get in the car and then you immediately
get stuck in gridlock traffic trying to
get in to the Holland Tunnel
the Lincoln Tunnel
the George Washington Bridge the
Triborough Bridge the [__] uh the
other tunnel over there
near where that guy [__] did the
headstand and fell off and Saturday
Night Fever
well well you guys I was looking for you
um
anyway
you know what the lesson in that part of
the movie is in Saturday Night Fever
when that kid didn't show up for the
fight
anyway were you guys I was looking for
you when he said that he did [__] be
like listen I backed my [__] car
through the goddamn front of the the
store
the bar whatever the [__] they were he
did do that
you know
that was something
okay but when he gets in there and those
guys were calling him a [__] and
everything he'd be like well you know
yeah I am
in order for you to be brave there has
to be a coward
or else everybody's just the same
so yes I guess I'm the coward of the
crew and judging by the big [__]
ace bandage on the side of your face it
was the right [__] decision to make
no
um
anyway and when you fly New York to LA
I'm just [__] awake the entire time
and uh just counting down the [__]
minutes so
but if you're gonna fly to like
Australia or over to Europe
or over to the Middle East
the family baggage right you fly all the
way the [__] out there you just like you
just resign yourself you're like all
right well I'm just on this thing
yeah I mean
what am I going to do here so what do
you do you [__] you watch two movies
you eat you watch two movies
that kills like
five hours of it four or five hours or
whatever
and then you go to sleep for eight
I don't know it just always works out
where I I watch two movies
then I go to sleep and I wake up and
there's like an hour and a half left in
the flight and that's what happened
on this one
so I watched
um
uh big George Foreman
was the first one that I watched
which was incredible I mean you know
what I gotta give a shout out to people
in the cast here they did such a great
job who was the kid who played George
Foreman
he was amazing and you know what I
aside from the acting performances the
accuracy
all right I'm an [__] I got my
recorder on and then the second I went
to the online I couldn't read anybody's
[__] name
I just did like another five minutes on
the podcast tonight that didn't record
all right so the guy playing George
Foreman was Chris Davis he was amazing I
the problem is they got half the cast
blocked out here Forest Whitaker was
amazing
um I'm gonna
butcher this name but the actress that
played George Foreman's first wife
s-h-e-i-n
and it looks like Mom premiere
she was amazing
uh uh the guy playing
um
is it Sullivan Jones I can see half the
name here the guy playing Muhammad Ali
was amazing obviously first Whitaker
um
I can't remember if I already said this
but what I was saying about the movie
what I loved was how the way they set it
up was you were immediately rooting
for George Foreman
you know I was even rooting for him not
to [__] up his life before he became a
boxer and I knew there was going to be a
boxer
you know
and you know when the heavyweight
championship and all this type of stuff
but even then you just was so invested
in the story it was just done perfectly
and as great as that movie was
I then watched one that was equally as
awful
um
yeah you're on international flight and
you just keep scrolling and scrolling
and scrolling and then they're getting
into like movies that you've never even
heard of and I just see this thing
and you know the English translation or
whatever the [__] it was the movie
because I've looked it up
it's called like nine different things
but on the plane it was called kill
Miami cops
and on the cover it it looked like
it looked like the actor that starred in
Super Fuzz and he looked good in a
uniform because he was in shape and then
there was this the other guy
the other guy looked like an opera
singer
you know he looked like Pavarotti's
brother
and he looked old as [__] and he was
[__] fat and he had this police
uniform on like he'd been walking the
beat for 50 [__] years and
the action in this movie the way it was
shot was just so [__] ridiculous and
like
the audio wasn't synced up with their
mouths or I couldn't even tell if they
were like not even speak in English and
it was dubbed into English I mean it was
it was a glorious
[__] show
of a [__] movie right so like this is
how bad the action was like there's a
big not the spoiler alert in case you're
gonna watch kill Miami cops
um
this this big shootout in the end in
this Warehouse
and at one point one of the bad guys who
of course have machine guns and the
other guys just have like pistols and
they're shooting like [__] 100
bullets a second the other guys are
shooting like from a [__] revolver
and somehow they're not getting hit and
they're killing guys with machine guns
so we've all seen that
in the 80s action movies right but
um
this one this one took it even to
another level where one of the bad guys
throws a [__] knife
at the in shape
actor that's dressed as a cop he throws
a [__] knife at him and then they cut
to to Pavarotti's brother he he reacts
to the knife being thrown he draws his
pistol he has all of this time as the
knife is
going towards the other dude and what
does he do he shoots the knife out of
the [__] air
one of the great shots of all time Jesus
[__] Christ if somebody [__]
knocks on my goddamn
door again here hang on a second hang on
okay bye all right thank you
all right
see that typical me I [__] and then I'm
happy they're here because they got the
[__]
I need some water here
um anyway
shoots the [__] knife out of the
goddamn air and then uh
and then the bad guys just do like
really dumb [__] it's like okay we have
machine guns and these guys have
revolvers and they're picking us off and
we can't kill them for some reason you
know be a great idea what if four of us
you know went over to a forklift one of
us drives it and the others get on the
pallet as he raises it up in the air
maybe that will be a good [__] idea
um
spoiler alert they all get [__] shot
hahaha
um you know what's funny is I actually
look them up
and they were ridiculously successful
and
um
the guy uh the guy I'm making fun of
that was overweight was actually an
Olympic
like metal winning swimmer at some point
in his life so the shape that he ended
up getting it
Because by the end of his when I was
watching him like his head looked like
it was as big as the police car like I
couldn't believe he could even get in
the [__] thing
um
so anyway I looked him up and I learned
all this stuff about him and all the
success they had him and that other guy
and uh I'm guessing either he got so
sick of training
to be an Olympic Athlete or maybe he got
injured or whatever he was just like or
he got sick of the Olympic diet and he
said [__] this
um
he's just one of those guys you know
like you know you watch an old movie and
you just look at someone you're like
there's no [__] way that guy's still
alive
and I was really surprised he lived well
into his 80s so I think all that
swimming helped him out
um because if he didn't swim and he
looked like that and he was eating the
food that we have in America that guy
would have dropped around 63 but he
lived well into his 80s so
congratulations to him but it is a
[__]
it if you just want to sit down and just
watch a [__] [__] show
with a friend of yours that really
enjoys a bad movie I highly recommend
kill Miami cops or something like that
Miami cops die
it didn't even make sense
because no cops die
[Laughter]
because I saw the cover and I'm like
wait are those two cops killing Miami
cops are they bad cops
let's go I don't know who knows that's
like kind of like over here when you
like travel
um
and you know what's funny like as far as
like people especially here in Europe
is like just some of the [__] that they
wear
like um like like a New York Yankees hat
it has nothing to do with the Yankees it
has to do I don't know about like
America or something
like America Ciao Bello Ciao Bella look
I just saw a couple I think they were
speaking German
I was sitting in this Cafe
you know just watching you know the
whole thing go by which is what I love
to do
and this couple shows up just total
label horse right
so the woman has on a white Yankee hat
and it's it's all white it has nothing
to do with the Yankees it's all white
and the Yankee logo
uh is in gold and then they said
something on the side that was also in
Gold like the MLB or something I don't
know what and it and then she had a
white Blazer on so like the cat Master
Blazer and then had like Chanel glasses
you know
ciao right remember that I love that
special what's his face did where he
kept going Chow that's what I just kept
thinking of and uh and then the other
guy the the dude German guy had on
um
I don't know what the [__] he had him
but he had a [__] hat on that had the
American flag on it and it said freedom
and then where the stars were would be
for the 50 states it had the Under Armor
um
like what do you call it the logo
and I just want to be excusing America
what in the [__] does that hat even mean
what the [__] does what are you guys
doing right now
um but you that's one of the things I
love coming going overseas and you just
see like these weird and like weird
names for movies and these weird
interpretations I mean we do the same
[__] to this stuff but I just don't know
because I'm living there so I'm not
acting like we're better or anything
it's just funny to watch like I remember
being in France one time and I just saw
this kid at a shirt and written in
English it just said Cuba best
people thought when they would see
Americans walking around with like a Che
Guevara is that how do you say his name
[__] that was the shirt to have
as like some white kid in the village
like yeah man [__] society and they
never realized the irony that this guy
was not into capitalism and then his
face had somehow become like you know
like the New York Yankees are like or or
you would see like American kids if like
if they were into soccer you just had a
man united [__] dream you didn't you
didn't it was just like the default
thing
right let's get some fish and chips man
united like you know you don't know
anything
king and queen uh [__] Princess Diana
you didn't know [__] anything
about it so um
anyway I'm I'm telling this story out of
order I got to tell you about going to
Dubai someplace I never in in um
I gotta tell you out of all the [__]
places I've been to and I've been to a
lot of them I don't think I've ever been
to a place where I out loud said I can't
[__] believe I'm here
as many times as I did when I was there
um I had such a great time
the people were amazing
it was [__]
it was hot okay I you don't even
it was another level
of like hot it was like 92 or 97 degrees
out at night at like midnight
and um
like
walking down the street like we landed
at night
all of us and we were like walking down
the street and we were like this
is no [__] joke this is uh it
affected however everybody just you have
this it's like you're still walking but
it's almost not walking
it's like you you are moving forward but
yeah
you are not
um you are not in a rush even though you
are your body just automatically knows
that like if I pick up the pace here I
might [__] fall down
um
and we the first night we went down and
there was this giant TV screen and we
sat outside at this bar
and we watched uh like the end of this
soccer
game and uh I always call it soccer and
I always will because it [__] annoys
people that aren't in America
um Cuba best soccer
um
we sat there
and I'm smoking a cigar which is so
stupid 97 degrees out
and I'm like look at that that's the
[__] Persian Gulf right there
I gotta go with it right so you know me
I'm terrified of any sort of body of
water so I go over there when I got up
to basically my knees and I took a
picture with Nate and Bianca and at one
point like this this thing of water went
up and I went what the [__] is that what
the [__] is that I didn't realize Bianca
there's sort of like splashed the water
up to add some something to the you know
young people they know how to Instagram
and they teased the [__] out of me
that I got like all I was thinking I
didn't think it was a shock I just
thought like something just did that and
something wants to eat that and then
something wants to eat that which at
that point I think is a shark as far as
the food chain goes I gotta get the [__]
out of here
so
anyway
um I don't think I've ever been so like
apprehensive before a goddamn show
because they were saying you know don't
talk about religion and don't make fun
of the country
and then there was a couple other things
and I was thinking like there was it's
like did they watch my tape like what in
the [__] why am I here
that's what I thought I the meal I ate
right before I went over there I was
like why am I here
the [__] was I thinking coming over here
with with my [__] act like a you
know and then of course I find out
you know some of the Royals the people
that run the country are going to be
there and I'm going oh Jesus Christ
I'm going to get this this isn't this
isn't going to be good and then people
going oh so and so came over here and
they said this and they got in trouble
right
so whatever so right before I go there
right I'm trying to psych myself up so
we're riding from Dubai over to Abu
Dhabi right
and we're driving down there
and you know everybody's kind of like
nervous like okay what can we talk about
what can we not talk about you know
right and uh then we get there and I
walked in the arena and it just felt
like a show
right
and I'm thinking like I don't want this
to be a bunch of expats
right I don't wanna I don't want to come
here and just perform in front of a
bunch of white guys that are like
[__] you know working for banks or
something so I peeked out and I saw a
nice mix of people
I saw the bankers you know and then I
saw the guys with the with the the that
onesie thing whatever they call Dish
Dash whatever whatever they call it
right uh which I swear to God if I spent
one more day there I was I would have
bought one because I'm like obviously
these things cool you off but I'm afraid
that if I put this thing on somebody's
gonna [__] be offended right I didn't
know right so um
I get there and Kenny goes okay I talk
to him
you can do your whole act there's not a
problem just don't make you know bring
up religion or or you know
make fun of the country
I said that's it they said oh yeah and
you can't say domestic violence
[Music]
and I said why and he goes I don't know
and I was like can I say slap the [__]
out of her and they was like well they
just said domestic violence I said I
[__] it I'm going to say it so anyway
Bianca goes up first
and there was just a crowd man they were
[__] great did whatever she wanted
she killed and then Nate went up there
and he was like talking you know joking
around about being there and they were
totally fine with that so by the time I
got up there
it was just like a show
and I went up there and the reception I
got I couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe it was like I was
playing like New Jersey or something
and I did my show and what I learned
doing the show
was uh uh how much you can learn about
people by what they laugh at and the way
they laugh at stuff
and um
I was getting those laughs that you know
there was one
joke that I was thinking of doing
where I bring up 911. and I was like I
don't know how they're gonna take this
and I did it and I got that [__]
laugh
um
as a comic right I always like if I'm
talking about something outside of me in
my world what I how do I do when I'm in
America is I look around the room to
make sure that the subject I'm talking
about
those people are laughing right like say
I'm doing a joke about race it involves
black people I'm not looking at the
white people in the crowd I'm looking at
the black people in the crowd and if
they're laughing in the right [__]
way
you know or if they're not laughing I
don't need to keep working on it or I
had this joke about Armenian people and
not only did they laugh they came up I
was like was that all right they were
like that 100 percent
I know exactly what you're talking about
right and I got that laugh
in Abu Dhabi and after that it was just
I was just cruising I had the best time
and uh
and then afterwards
um
it was it was such a funny conversation
they you know they said that it's
customary that if the royal family comes
down you got to meet them and they go do
you want to meet him before or after the
show and I hate meeting people before
the show
because I want to focus on the show and
then
if I meet him after if they didn't like
it they'll just leave and if they like
it they come down so it's kind of a
better thing so
um anyways the show ends
and I I was looking at Kenny was that
fine he goes totally fine Live Nation
everybody said it was fine I said great
I said uh are the royal family people
coming down and Kenny's like
um His Highness had to leave but his
Excellency is coming down
[Laughter]
so I ended up meeting his Excellency and
he was cool as hell I said your
Excellency it's nice to meet you when he
left he goes ah call me and he said his
name which you know my head was spinning
at that point
um
and uh he was a cool guy we took
pictures and all that type of stuff
and uh
and then that was it the next day we
like flew out but like the level of
relieved
that the three of us were
and then what was funny was after that
like I heard all these other stories you
know so and so came here and had to sign
something saying they wouldn't say that
again
but whatever whatever they're they're on
their way that's what I'm gonna say the
crowd is already ready
you know for stand-up comedy but like
they're on their way
um because I feel like even since the
last time whoever played before they've
loosened up even more and and they were
totally cool and the crowd was amazing
and um
this is what's really funny you know who
calmed me down about going over there
you know
I actually ended up you know I go to
this this uh
I go to this place you know
every once in a while and I ran into
this guy
I don't know why I just started talking
to him he just had this approachable
thing
and he uh acidic Jewish guy right
and you know he's a funny guy and we're
just always like busting each other's
chops or whatever and talking about life
so Santa said man I go I'm going over to
uh
I'm going over to you know Abu Dhabi and
I go I'm nervous about this thing or
whatever
and I said you know I can't talk about
this I can't talk about that and he's
like what can you talk about I go I
think I can make fun of the Jews
so he cracks up
I go I'm just [__] with you and I go
I know it's going to be good I just
wanted then he goes look he goes just
he goes the world's a positive place he
goes this you know certain areas you
know it's new they're not and he just
put me in that mindset they're not ready
for that yet so rather than looking at
it like you know you're not letting me
do my [__] I was just like you know go
over there
and just don't be an [__] and then
other Comics will get to do it and then
eventually
it'll just be little
they'll see what they they see over here
like Comics tell jokes and it doesn't
affect anything everybody just has a
good time so
um the show ends
uh you know and uh
uh we got this great picture and um
I could I can't even tell you what a a
um
how mind-blowing it was I think I said
that in the show to go that far away
from where I live
and have anybody even know who the hell
I am was was unbelievable and do you
know I was sitting at the hotel
and uh
this waiter came up asked me you know
you want something to drink or whatever
so I got like a water and he goes oh I
don't want to bug you but I'm a fan of
your stuff I was like really he goes
yeah he goes that Philly rant was great
I go you saw the Philly rant
all the way over here he's like yeah
I was like did you even know what I was
talking about he's like well I mean I
knew you were making fun of the local
teams and it was funny
um so I just kept having
um
experiences like that so it was uh
my head is still spinning so I
definitely I'm definitely going to do
the gig again uh I'm not gonna do it in
August I can [__] tell you that right
now Jesus Christ
oh my God
you know I mean I don't think I've ever
appreciated air conditioning
uh the way I did on that trip holy [__]
I mean you want to talk about like
you'd be walking down the street you
would be so [__] hot
that like when you walked into air
conditioning you'd almost be worried
you're going to catch pneumonia
oh oh oh I almost forgot
so I told the story when I was on stage
about going into the Persian Gulf when
they started yelling going now they're
going
they go Arabian golf
I'm like what I thought they're saying
Arabian golf I didn't know what they
were talking about they go they they
call it the Arabian Gulf
and I was like oh all right I was like
whatever
I'm [__] American we renamed [__]
it's what we do and they got a big laugh
on that
um I don't know it was a great time so
thank you to everybody over there for
having me
um
and thank you for uh
you know Nate Bianca open in the show it
went great and now now it's all downhill
skiing here I got Prague tonight
and then I just do my next run of shows
and uh
yeah I was really really happy
that that whole thing uh
that whole thing went well
um
it's sort of the [__] you just go
through that when you when you're on
like the road man it's just like this
far away it's just like you have this
act
that works in the states and then you
just leave and you're like well they
you just hear these like you want to go
out to the Middle East like [__] yeah I
would love to
when am I ever going to get to go then
you get there and you're like what in
the [__] am I going to talk about that
they're even gonna
my ACT is so American and they need to
see this [__]
like when I was like talking about being
married and everything listening
and the men and women laugh it's the
exact [__] Saint they're going
through the exact same [__] exact same
[__]
um
pretty well why can't I get this thing
to shut off I somehow turned on the
notification so I should turn that off
right
all right well I'm gonna hit pause here
anyways because I have to go eat dinner
it's late here so once again thank you
to everybody that came out
um in Abu Dhabi I I could not have had a
better time and um really
hope it's not a once in a lifetime
experience but it's it's fun
to to go someplace
that far away and actually connect
with people like that it was pretty
pretty uh
pretty mind-blowing I don't think I'd
even like processed it yet but as you
can tell as I continue to talk about it
like it was one of the biggest thrills
of my
um
stand-up career to have a set that good
I'll tell you Mumbai India
was that it's right when I went to
Mumbai India like
so much of the crowd was the local
stand-up comedians which is you know the
highest honor
you could get it I remember afterwards
hanging out with them talking comedy and
they were asking the exact same [__]
questions that comedians in the states
act asked it was uh
it was um
mind-blowing
[__] mind-blowing so
um
I was talking to some people after the
show and I was saying like you know I'm
definitely I want to come back and they
were like great and I said I don't want
to come back in the summer but I love F1
and Moto GP and they're like yeah let's
do it let's hook it up so
um if you missed the show and you're
over there I will definitely be back
and um but you you will not see me there
in August oh my God thank God for that
hotel pool
the three of us and club soda Kenny we
were just in the [__] pool it was
[__] awesome the pool was awesome the
hotel was beautiful but like uh
it was sort of like the perfect hang and
you know what was good though what was
good is because it was off season there
wasn't a bunch of tourists there so we
could just kind of had to pull
mostly to ourselves
um
that happened to me a long time ago when
I went on my honeymoon I went to the uh
French Riviera
oh freckles out in front of his skis
[__] French Riviera right and uh we
went to uh
[__] was the name of that place
I would have I'll remember it later on
the podcast
um
one of those places I always heard about
when I was
you know unlike People magazine
when they would show like Mick Jagger
and the latest hot chick he was [__]
banging right
San Tropez
um let's say we're trying to avoid taxes
Exile on Main Street all that [__] uh I
went down there and uh we got there
before
the um
because you were there in April and they
were like the people tell us because it
was like one Road in
and they were like in one month's time
that's gonna take about like [__]
whatever like four hours to get down
that street to come here and it's just
gonna be just
and uh I gotta be honest with you to me
that is not a [__] vacation it is not
a [__] vacation just walking around
standing in line that's why I don't do
any touristy [__] although I did in
Dubai
I went to the tallest building in the
world
and
and this giant mall they had a [__]
full-on aquarium with like sharks and
[__] and scuba divers
[__] wild so we all went all the way
up to the top
all the way up to the top
and uh the people there man are funny
they're [__] funny they drive
aggressively like New Yorkers East Coast
people Boston
which
um
you know that's how I grew up so I
totally respected that but then like the
touristy game was [__] hilarious like
we after we went upstairs we came
downstairs and this guy had like a
camera and he wanted us to get the
touristy picture you know
and he's like my friend my friend sit
down sit down I'm like nah man I'm good
he goes my friend sit down and he got
like really [__] aggressive
[Music]
and I had to look at him and be like no
[__] funny as hell man
my friend my guy's like dude I don't
feel like your friend the way you're
talking that [__] town I don't feel
like your friend so um
that you know he's just doing that thing
you know this the hustle or whatever but
I I liked it had like a [__] uh
you know people were cool but there was
like that East Coast vibe kind of thing
uh that I really liked so anyway that's
it so that's Dubai now I am in Prague
um
just incredible and today I went over to
that church where I you know saw this
whole documentary
on how
um seven
Czech soldiers whacked I'll get all the
information here
um I'm just about ready to go out to
dinner but they whacked this [__]
one of the most murderous piece of [__]
Nazi guys they [__] murdered the guy
and then they will hide and then that
church
and they always go somebody betrayed
where they were at it's like you mean
got tortured I don't know how it is but
whatever and then like the seven of them
held off like 700 Nazis
for I don't know how long
and
like I think three of them got killed
upstairs and then they were downstairs
and they still were fighting them off
and in the end when they had killed as
many of the Nazis as they could and they
knew they were going to get overrun they
just all committed suicide and you go
down there and it's just like it's on
this the bullet holes are still
in the uh
you know in the walls man it's [__]
wild and uh one of the
you know I mean that's right they were
like the beaches in Normandy all of that
stuff is just amazing those the stories
and and the the
bravery of the people and um
I I remember I I come here like four
years ago and then heard about the story
after I was like [__] I would have loved
to have seen that so
um I'll tell you what's wild about the
story is
that when Germany took check uh
and they they didn't even like they
didn't even have like a decision like
there was like a meeting between Germany
somebody else in like England they don't
even have like the Czech president even
there he doesn't even get to make the
[__] decision in England co-signed on
it because they didn't want to have
another world war
and they kind of let them take Austria
and then
check thinking that they were just going
to stop I guess was the idea so
um
I just can't imagine being that
President like having to make that like
what do I do here
like the German Army do I just say [__]
that and [__] what you guys just signed
I mean
and then I'm and then you know on a
bunch of countrymen are going to get
killed
blah blah blah
do I agree with this like having to make
that [__] decision
knowing that no matter which way you go
you know if you don't say anything
they're going to look at you like you're
you know
you just gave up the country and then
what was [__] up is is then you see
what seven guys were able to do then you
got to be thinking like well [__] man if
that's
that kind of balls my people have I
should have fought these guys
there was you know what it was there
really was no [__] who you know this
is all hindsight
um
you know I was just reading these things
today so this is all like new
information to me so I'm probably
getting a lot of this wrong but like one
of the things that fascinated me was
then at the end of the war
um
you know
the same people that sold them out to
the Germans were now looking at them
like well you fought on the you were
part of the German
side and it's like it's like no we
weren't you [__]
you [__] English [__] you [__]
sold this out you didn't even give us
the decision it's just
you know
it's the same old [__]
my country does that we'll put somebody
in power
you know because he's gonna [__] with
somebody else think you know who I'm
talking about and then years later he
becomes the bad guy and it's like Oh you
mean the guy that was our guy that we
helped get into power now we're gonna
act like we don't even know the guy
um all right I'm I'm getting too [__]
deep here World politics is not my
specialty a lot of things aren't my
specialty but you know what stand-up
comedy is God damn it and I had a great
[__] scent in Abu Dhabi
um
which is [__] awesome because now I
am beyond excited
um for the rest of this tour
and um I'm spending a couple days here
in Prague which I did on purpose because
uh Bianca's from here and she's been
taking us out to all the spots and it's
just been [__] amazing the only thing
it sucks the lovely Nia is not here
because we got the kiddos
oh my God can I tell you something
[__] hilarious my daughter said to me
the other day what she just said about
me
she said dad used to have hair but he
outgrew it
just said it matter of factly
to her little brother
because she's always singing songs that
have bald dad in it and she just thinks
it's the funniest thing ever and of
course I'm laughing my ass she trashes
me and which you know to me is the
highest form
of affection you know when somebody like
is trashing you like that and she sees
me laughing and then she just does it
even more
but she was playing with their little
brother
and she's getting him teaching him how
to say bald dad
and they were playing with I don't know
what the hell they were playing with and
she just looks over him she goes yeah
dad used to have hair but he outgrew it
and she wasn't even trying to be funny
she was trying to explain the process of
going bald
[Music]
um all right I'm gonna go get something
to eat and I'll I'll come back I'll do
the Reeds and all of that [__] all right
all right I guess I'm not going to
dinner
I lost track of the time and everybody
already went no worries all right let me
just knock this podcast out then all
right let's do some reads here
oh look who it is indochito
you know personal style isn't just about
having a signature look you can Define
your style piece by piece and fall is
the perfect time to add a few new layers
to your wardrobe elevate your closet
with indochino for custom made to
measure pieces at an off the rack price
this season indochito has new colors
fabrics and styles to choose from from
Classic Suits for special occasions to
head turning out outerwear for your
sidewalk stride with new colors fabrics
and outerwear Styles it's easy to create
your fall look their unique process
allows you to choose the exact
customizations you want from buttons and
vents to pockets and lapels you say how
you want it and that's how they'll build
it submit your measurements online or
book a showroom appointment to work with
an indochino expert style guide in
person Blazers pants outerwear and more
designed and made for for you hundreds
of high quality Fabrics to choose from
quality European wools linen and cotton
in a wide range of colors and patterns
designed hey look personalized to your
style and all of that [__] all right
here we go add fresh layers to your fall
Style with indochino go to indochino.com
and use the code Burr b-u-r-r to get 10
off any purchase at 3.99 or more that's
ten percent sent off at
[Music]
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code Burr
oh look who it is everybody it's old zip
right up
uh did you know that if you're an
employer who's hiring the average cost
per hire is 4 700 bucks
what are you getting a call girl
um if you're investing that much money
into each new hire you want to get it
you want to get it right
so what's the most effective way to find
the best people for your rose zip
yeah
uh see for yourself right now you can
try for free at ziprecruiter.com
experience the value ZipRecruiter brings
to hiring
uh lets you try before you commit
there's no cost to try you can post jobs
for free so you can see for yourself how
effective it is in helping you hire
um
gives you the power to zero in one gives
you the power to zero
oh zero in on top talent
got your eye on an accident candidate no
problem it lets you reach out to him you
can easily send candidates you're really
interested in a personal invite to apply
to help your job Stand Out amongst the
competition it's simple zip yeah uh
helps you get hiring right four to five
employers will post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
web address to try it for free before
you commit uh ziprecruiter.com
again that's ziprecruiter.com spell
outbur b-u-r-r uh ZIP recruiter
the smartest way to hire
oh look who it is oh Jesus Christ
the most loyal of all loyal as far as
advertisers go stamps.com
they've been with me since I had hey
um the Holiday Rush means more mailing
and shipping for your business but it
doesn't have to mean more stress
you can put your feet up and rub your
balls with stamps.com it has been
helping businesses Like Yours save time
and money for 20 25 years I didn't know
they were on that long and it can help
you get ready for the holiday ramp up
all you need is stamps.com's premium
rates for all your postage needs uh your
own personal post office wherever you
are with stamps.com all you need is a
computer and a printer uh they even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to get started and if you sell
products online Sam stuff stamps.com
seamlessly connects with every major
Marketplace and shopping
card uh premium discounts and supplies
at your fingertips running low our
shipping and mailing supplies
labels and even printers from the supply
store are available get huge carrier
discounts up to 84 percent off uh USPS
and UPS rates to help your bottom line
plus stamps.com automatically tells you
your cheapest and fastest shipping
options your postage partner for the
last 25 years get your business ready
for the holiday Rush get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code bird for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term commitment or contracts just
go to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the home page and enter the
code Burr alright now it is time for
your questions and comments
um oh Bill let the listeners know the
Monday Morning podcast live at the
Troubadour 3 is up on YouTube
uh yes we filmed it we did like a three
two three camera shoot and
um this was the one that was on moment
I don't know four or five months ago and
we just well I enjoyed it
you know doing the podcast so much
that we decided to put it out there and
uh this is something that I think I'm
gonna do more if you guys enjoy it if
you want to watch the podcast
um
I definitely uh would like to do more of
these
um I might even do a live podcast
overseas
sticking how cool that would be
um
all right live podcast uh yo Bill the
live podcast was one of the greatest
things I've ever seen thank you for two
free hours of Comedy Off the goddamn
cuff impressive stuff Bill hope that
Catholic guilt doesn't keep you from
realizing how talented you are oh
well you know I've been doing this doing
this for a long time running my Yap by
myself so I just do it in front of the
crowd
I also uh
I don't know I also [__]
just connected with the crowd the crowd
does sound quiet we crowd a lot of
people like going great show but what's
up with that uptight [__]
you know La crowd people are so dumb
it's like they came to see me do the
podcast they listened to the podcast
their podcast listeners so I don't think
that they're uptight I think you just
can't hear them
um they all had a great time they were
fantastic like the crowd in Abu Dhabi
all right uh look at this you working
out bruh
hey [__] Billy biceps I saw Randy
Blythe posted a photo of you on
Instagram and Jesus you looked ripped as
[__] on the drum set I did
I'll take that well listen as good as
the arms are looking just know that the
[__] you know
I got a nice [__] belly too don't ever
forget that uh you've been lifting yes I
have been but you know what I've been
doing I've been old man lifting weights
which is I finally
have given in to the fact that I'm old
so I don't
um
I don't lift heavy weight
um I I just do weight that I can easily
handle and I just do reps until I feel a
good burn and then I'm like all right so
that's the number and that's what I'll
do for three sets it doesn't take a lot
to keep yourself toned that's what I've
realized but it does take a lot
to increase your muscles HGH
either that you got to eat half a
[__] cow every day
um and I'm not doing that all right so
I'm just gonna be uh
I'm trying to keep myself but thank you
for saying that because I got a little
out of sorts here when I was in well I
was staying in Dubai and it's just like
what am I am I not going to try the food
you know
oh my God we had great food when we were
there
but you know I I went to they had a
killer gym at the hotel and uh I used it
one day but the other days I did not so
um
I've been good while I was in Prague and
I gotta tell you something
um if ever I'm gonna go off the [__]
wagon it's going to be in Europe
because
my country really needs to up their game
when it comes to serving
beer
um
the [__] mugs like I've been over
here
like these giant mugs of beer
I saw like an old lady
like this old couple and they both had
these giant mugs of beer in front of
them
and I was just like that's [__] just
the afternoon and you know they just
drinking having a good time I saw a mom
with her mom and a baby in a baby
carriage she was like in her mid-30s and
it was just like the middle of the day
and she had a giant
like I'm not talking about a pint it was
this giant
[__] like medieval size mug it looked
[__] delicious
and uh I'm not gonna lie to you for the
first time in a long time I thought what
if I just had one
and then my brain quickly told me the
answer well one will become two
and then you'll go off the rails on this
trip and then what you're gonna do is
lie to yourself that when I get back to
the States it's gonna stop it won't stop
and then I'll have to quit again which
was hard enough the first time so [__]
that
but God damn anyway it says uh you've
been lifting it's cool as [__] to see my
all-time favorite comedian with my
favorite band of all time Lamb of God
yes that was the band I was talking
about I want to be Billy fancy pants but
um
I went down
in uh once Chris Adler who I'm also a
huge huge fan of
um I still can't play all this stuff
those drum things tracks
that Chris played he left the band a
number of years ago our Cruz is the new
Drummer I met him one night randomly I
was at The Comedy Store
and he said yeah I got a new gig and he
was I was like well yeah because I'm I'm
I got the Lamb of God gang oh that's
amazing so whatever he had he let me
come down I watched him play soundcheck
in this [__] amazing venue I want to
do a show there
um
I guess he used to be an old movie
theater but it felt like oh I talked
about this like an old tree you could
just tell like this is gonna be a sweaty
[__] massive Humanity losing their
mind [__] rock show
you just you just knew you just knew you
could feel it and uh but I got to watch
some new sound check and I I hung out
with some of the guys got some coffee
I had a great time
um anyway uh how was the show
I didn't see the show the guy says I've
been so busy lately I didn't even know
they were playing Riverside I always go
to their shows when they are in Southern
California Randy's Instagram post
mentioned you jammed a couple Tunes with
them on the drums uh no I went up and I
played a little bit
I [__] around a little bit
um
and it was funny because they had the
drum kit miked up
when art was playing with them and it
sounded gigantic and then when I got on
there the sound guy clicked it off so
I felt like when I was playing I sounded
like I was on like a [__] toy drum
kit I also was going on after a
professional drummer so anyway first
which songs did you jam with second what
is your favorite Lamb Of God song
oh God you're gonna put me on my old
brain
oh [__]
oh let's go into let's go into the uh
let's go into the library here
I'll show you the the album that got me
into them
if I could find it
I bet if I listen to it now I could
figure out some of the drums
um these are the ones I have I
ashes of the wake
was the first one
uh oh now you got now you've got shotgun
94. that was a great one omerto was
great
uh
that was 2004 and that's that's where I
was mentally
oh that [__] came out
so
um
I've been on like a jazz kick lately uh
uh 2006 Sacrament that's one and then
the last album I bought for them
was the self-titled one in 2020
.
um I can't play any of that [__] but if
you want to get into my library here the
late the last couple things that I
downloaded was uh
this band called The Pretty Things
parachute
and the best is Sam Cooke
and Joe Henderson power to the people
which I think has Al Foster on drums uh
who played with Miles Davis that's how I
know about him but um that's what I've
been doing but no I didn't sit down like
those guys are on [__] tour they
don't have time to do a Make-a-Wish jam
session with me especially when you know
you know what I did I sat down and I was
thinking what am I going to play so I
was thinking I was playing Pantera I was
actually playing Primus Jerry Was a Race
Car Driver I was like wait that's not
what I was trying to play I was trying
to play the uh the Double Bass part in
uh Cowboys from Hell
um and of course I I busted out my
bottom triplets you know I did a little
bit of that I went around the toms a
couple of times that was it it wasn't it
wasn't long but it was uh his drum kit
is [__] gorgeous
gorgeous
uh Ludwig kick which I'm so happy that
Ludwig is back
because when I was coming up in the 80s
they had a a time where they they kind
of lost their way kind of like BMW BMW
was making great cars and I don't know
what the hell happened
they went from a [__] a three five
and a seven to a one series a two a
three and four five eight it's like
boxing where all of a sudden they had
like nine million weight classes and 53
[__] Champions
um Everybody after a while loses their
way I've lost my way
right
I used to have a full head of hair and
[__] my life ahead of me now look at
me
I outgrew it
um
yeah it was uh I will tell you the as
cool as it was to play his kit it was
even cooler
to be standing behind
you know the drum kit watching him play
and trying to figure out
like what was going on
because I've watched Chris Adler play
them he did a modern drummer I have this
on DVD somewhere he did one of those
modern drummer like drum day things or
whatever and modern drummer would put
out the DVD every year and I remember I
watched that over and over and over
again and he had like like they didn't
show his feet enough and he would sort
of hop almost like Steve Gad when he
would play which is really cool and when
I watched art play those parts like he
does
like he plays heel up and heal down
like like whatever he needs to do to get
it
it was it was like he kind of was doing
both
and I'll be honest with you I I you know
watching it at full speed I I don't know
that I learned anything other than he's
a the you know an amazing drummer
um
all right pizza and arm hair
okay hey Bill
uh I'm standing in line watching a guy
make my pizza the dough oh no the dough
he throws around touches his arm
some hair at some poker
has to have got in the dough
at some point this is a classic voice
text
it says some some hair and some poker
has to have gone into some hair at some
point uh I'm not a germaphobe but it got
me thinking that thousands of arm hairs
have been eaten with pizza help me
forget this fact and tell me why I'm
wrong I'll tell you why you're wrong is
because rather than keeping that
information to yourself you've now
infected all of our brains with it
um
I don't give a [__] I'm still eating
pizza
but I do like that's my only thing I
don't like about pizzas I don't like
watching somebody I don't know prepare
my food
you know
like if my wife's making me dinner I I
enjoy that it's like that's right
you work for me this is the power
structure you are the woman you go in
the kitchen and you make me a [__] me
I'm kidding
um no I don't like watching strangers
handle my food
even if back in the day like you're at
like a Subway and they put on those
[__]
you know what I was loved is when
somebody would put on like the rubber
gloves
and then they just leave them on all day
and they're talking to you and they're
like rubbing their nose but it's like so
at this point you're just protecting
your hands from you
but all of you is is [__] on those
gloves
you ever do that order what do you want
you're like let me get this this and
then you just see something like that
you're like you know what I gotta I know
what I wanna order I wanna I wanna order
forget it forget about it I'm all no no
I'm good I'm good keep the money I
didn't want to go through the whole
[__] do you just take that buddy
you take all that money and you [__]
go buy some hand sanitizer with it all
right song I Can't Stand
hey Billy bald bag big fan of the
podcast long time listen up blah blah
blah
on to the [__] talking I personally
can't stand the song Come On Eileen uh
by dexie's Midnight Runners and I have
two theories as to why yeah I [__]
hated that song
I [__] hated that song when it came
out
Come On Eileen and then
then they just sort of morphed into a
cover
[Music]
dinner
baby baby where did I love go
and I just hated the sound of the
keyboard
but now I go back and I listen to it and
it reminds me of that period in my life
so I don't mind it but uh that's a good
call yeah I [__] hated that song all
right first of all my first ever
girlfriend made it our song
he put that in quotes in other words he
had no say in that when we were
teenagers and I can't for the life of me
remember when how or why
well I mean that should have given you
good memories unless you broke your
heart
uh there was something smug about this
self
mythologic behavior that I can't help
but think about her every time I hear it
side note it's incredibly likely the
origin story occurred during
some early teenage binge drinking bouts
hence the lapse in memory
um
I'm starting to understand why she broke
up with you did you immediately just go
from zero to 900 with your drinking like
I did uh secondly and speaking of
drinkers similar to your aforementioned
Neil Diamond Stadium pleaser I think
that the persist participation in the
breakdown section
um Come On Eileen is what is the most
infuriating for me the tempo slowing
down and everyone's singing come on I
mean
that's awful
do you ever think they they know that
they have to know that like we're in
when they're in the studio
you know they have they got to know that
[__]
that that's like all right we gotta dumb
this down if we we're trying to sell out
a [__] Arena here
let's just write some mindless [__]
that is fun to sing
um
I just remember too like the lead singer
looked like he like a street person he
looked like he was homeless
it was another thing I didn't like I
liked like [__] you know I hated
myself growing up so I like seeing rock
stars that made me want to be them
so maybe when I saw that guy he looked
like a brunette me
who knows but God bless him they wrote a
hit and they're still living off of it
God willing
um
oh that's so he's oh he goes the tempo's
slowing down and everyone's saying Come
On Eileen
and banging their fists against the bar
like they're suddenly committed to
living in the musical universe and ready
to break into song at a moment's notice
yeah
that was like the Mony Mony get lit get
[__]
[__] acid wash jeans
oh God those were such lonely years for
me
I had friends but I just remember
everything I looked at I was just like
no that's not it you know just searching
like where do I fit in and when I was
people go get leg get [__]
um
I don't know what bus this is but I I
I'm getting off getting off the next
time this bus stops I'm [__] getting
off this thing
I don't know what this is um
there's only two places I ever felt like
I fit in and it was working in a
warehouse and working in a comedy club
it's the only two places where the
people that were in there were wired
like I was construction site a little
bit but they they
had different brains than mine they were
like good with their hands like building
[__] like knowing like a trade like I
wasn't those guys
um
I don't know I always felt people that
worked in warehouses were smart enough
to not get involved in landscaping
you know being a grunt doing that just
because it just beats the [__] out of
your body you know what I mean
it's like everybody knows if you're
going to enlist
in the armed services Armed Forces right
if you want to get treated like a human
being you you
as much as possible you join the Navy or
the Air Force
like they have the best accommodations
I've heard this from veterans it's like
you know
if you want to get knocked around and
get treated like you you know
on a whole other level you join the Army
or the Marines
um which is probably why the Army and
Marines have like you know
are considered like more badass
oh let's get this going huh how would
you rank them it's college football
season I'm over here missing out
the Marines have probably considered the
most badass
then the army
the Navy I feel like is sort of
ambiguous it's like I feel like you're
really smart
you know
they got those really lovely uniforms I
mean they're UNIF I mean I would say the
Marines they're dress uniforms are the
best
um then maybe the Navy
and then Air Force I love Aviation
but the funny thing about the Air Force
is most people don't end up flying the
Jets
you know that's a bit I used to do like
I'm in the Air Force you fly the Jets no
I'm the guy that does that yoga suppose
and I point in the direction that the
Jets takes off
[Laughter]
especially after Top Gun right and now
they brought Top Gun backs everybody's
like oh yeah you Goose will you Maverick
will you [__] Range Rover what was
your [__] call signs uh
I put the gas in it I'm that guy I'm
like a [__] F-16 roadie I set up and
break it down that's that's what I do
um
isn't it amazing those guys flying those
[__] planes right
and they can handle all those G's and
all of that [__] and then and then they
get all this all these chicks want to
[__] bang them but the guy that
actually the mechanics that work on
those [__] things like if it breaks
down they know how to fix it they know
how to fix like a [__] hundred
million dollar goddamn airplane
and no one gives a [__]
shout out to mechanics knowing how to
fix all this stuff so the world keeps
running you still have to work you still
got to work on the weekends to try to
get some woman to love you
um I relate as a comedian
we used to always be jealous of
musicians because they could go up there
and sing their songs and then they get
off stage and the chicks would just be
running up to them whereas comedians we
would do our [__] you get off stage and
then they would you know if they came up
to you they wanted you to continue to be
funny like the show like never ends
um all right song I Can't Stand uh dear
Billy copper bush
I like that I like the idea that my
pubes are the color of a precious metal
um
and just like copper over time they
change color
love the podcast and all that you do
you've been talking you've been talking
the past few podcasts about songs you
can't stand and for me
it's got to be Africa by Toto oh all
I can't co-sign on that
I love that band and I love that song
even though I have no idea what he's
saying
that guy what a [__] voice
it was funny he was just asked to leave
the band
they didn't kick he was such a good
singer they just listen man he you're
doing too much blow you got it you gotta
[__] chill out here
then hey [__] talk to Daddy I have no
idea what he says
um you don't crush that song
about the goddamn Comedy Jam big J sang
the [__] hell out of that [__]
killed it
if you ever see big J on on The Comedy
Jam go
there I saw him sing another song
uh what the [__] was this song
hey say it ain't so oh he had the whole
place singing it
um all right I'm 23 and regularly go out
to college Buzz where that song is
played Africa
is played pretty much every night all
right I don't want to hear that song
every night and while everyone in the
room is screaming the words at the top
of their lungs My Blood starts to boil
to the point of wanting to commit a hate
crime I know what you're saying
that does this like
I think Sports is the only time where I
I feel like I want to be part of the
crowd
where every time else when I just see uh
you know everybody this losing their
mind about a song
yeah it's weird how those old songs are
catching on you know I went to a USC
basketball game
and they had that Journey song on
Don't Stop Believing and these kids were
losing their [__] minds now it didn't
bother me because there's an old guy I
thought it was like oh my God like this
is cool that these young kids think
anything that
came out in my generation that was a
little before
my teenage years when that came out
anyway
the guy says hand down that has to be
the gayest song released by a rock band
in the 80s would you agree no
no
if not what are some of the other gay
rock songs released from that era thanks
and go [__] yourself
uh
I gotta think I gotta think
well you know it was funny
was a lot of the songs that when I was a
kid and I was listening to metal so like
I'm like that song that sounds gay right
and then meanwhile I would watch a guy
in full makeup
essentially dressed like a woman
um but there was guitar and to me
that was that that song has balls right
so I mean if you saw some of the [__] I
was listening to uh
and it was considered metal and it was
like
and you go back and you watch and you're
like going oh my God this is like
this is like Rocky Horror Picture Show
which I've never seen but it was it I
don't know
um
wasn't some of the lame rock songs
I guess she's not supposed to say gay
anymore right you're supposed to say
you're supposed to use it like that
knock it off remember that
um
this always happens to me with music why
can't I [__] remember
I'm gonna get one I'm gonna get one uh
all right I'm just gonna start naming
songs that I liked that were a little
out of my wheelhouse
that one band one of that she's a beauty
she's wanted a million girls remember
that rock that wasn't like hard rock
it was pop
like uh
what was the other guy I was in jeopardy
baby I [__] love that song
oh eight six seven five three
like whatever that was
that part of Rock
God damn it you know what you caught me
give me a I'll answer this on the next
one
um I would say like any of those ballads
that were like
like say like REO Speedwagon
oh that come on
like sticks right like those were bands
like it's like what the [__] are you
guys doing
are you a rock band or are you trying to
be more like you know rock opera like I
don't know what the [__] is going like I
could never like I was fine with those
bands there early [__]
it's like their early [__]
was
it had balls to it and then at some
point the lead singer you know the guy
that plays piano
that [__] guy which is just not rock
man there's no keyboards and rock man
that was all of that [__] like once that
guy's ego like took over he got big
enough and then all of a sudden he
starts calling the shots
you know
um
but that didn't always uh that wasn't
always a bad thing
because early Journey
was like actually I think they were like
more like a prog rock band and then when
Steve Perry got in he took him in this
different direction but then they made
all these great songs so there's no you
know what people there are no absolutes
but uh [__]
such a good question I know there's so
many of these songs
when I was growing up but now I like
most of them I like now like I remember
I hated Culture Club
I was just I couldn't relate to the
music at all I was weirded out that
there was some dude dressed like a woman
while watch you know
like Boy George wood could have dressed
the exact same [__] way
except have an electric guitar
and had some [__] heavy rips and I'd
be like [__] Boy George rocks like
that was so it was so [__] stupid
right but I was stupid I was I was dumb
back then now
I listened to to uh boy I got two right
here that uh how about this songs that
you used to think
were lame and then you go back and
listen to him you're like oh that's
actually really good I would say Boy
George and Simply Red
when I was [__] growing up I was like
man [__] those bands
[__] those bands I [__] [__]
[__]
now listen to the guy simply read him
like that guy's voice is [__]
unbelievable
and then that song do you really want to
hit me you used to drive me up the
[__] wall and now I listen to him
like the drum the [__] drum group on
this is [__] insane it's amazing and
then also this is sort of like blending
genres this is actually really high
level pop music here the [__] was wrong
with me
oh
dude the amount of makeup by the way
sold in the 80s that has to be the best
ERA ever it was like everyone was
wearing it
Prince was wearing it
uh
Prince I had an on-again off against fan
thing in the 80s
you know
he would do like uh oh no let's go in a
[__] rock and I would like it and
then all of a sudden he was getting out
of a bathtub naked and I was like what
the [__] is this and I would have to
walk away
it all comes down to personal preference
but then in the end I go back
and at this age and I listened to it and
I kind of love all of it and I just
realized that I was just a [__] idiot
kid
and and you'll do that you know what one
of these days I'm calling it right now
you're going to listen to that song
Africa and you're actually going to like
it because it's going to remind you of
being in college and having your whole
life ahead of you all right before you
[__] out grew your hair all right
that's it everybody go [__] yourselves
thanks to everybody in uh Abu Dhabi who
came out to my show
um I had such a great time it was a
mind-blowing experience and I hoped I
get to do it again and
um I'm looking forward to Prague tonight
Berlin Stockholm Budapest and then I'm
in Athens it's going to be [__]
insane all right that is it I will talk
to you later